so guys this is the third film in this
series but you actually shot this one
and the fourth one back to back right
yeah
you guys are
are wrapped you're done with these
characters how does that feel
they're sweet
very sweet yeah first week is a very
good word to describe how it feels um
the nice thing is though it doesn't ever
feel like it's actually done because
we're still here talking to you
hopefully we'll be back here next year
for the fourth one um and i'm sure it
will never be done done we'll always
we'll always do some stuff to you know
continue the journey somehow
yeah okay so what would you say you're
going to miss the most about each other
to be honest i've said that we've said i
think i i'm don't think it'll be very
rare that i have the opportunity to work
with another person on the same four
films so the fact that we were able to
bring the same characters to life and it
was both of our first
lead role and therefore like to have
that journey of you know your first four
lead movies essentially um to have
someone else on the journey with you is
um
is i don't know i'm going to compare it
to but it's lovely and i'll definitely
miss that
yeah i can only imagine okay so look in
the previous two films we know that tess
and hardin they got they got the
intensity thing going on so in this film
out of 10 how intense is their
relationship
[Music]
you knew we were going to say that you
set that one up
so why 11.
well i think we already we started at 10
didn't we so that was only you can only
go up from there in i feel like we
started at 10 intensity or they did um
sorry i got on joe no just i think the
steaming
steaming the steaminess and you know the
the number of those scenes and the
relationship and the intensity of it
it's just it can only go up from
here
yeah you know i mean those scenes people
love those scenes
you know when you're doing like a third
and a fourth are they just like all
right let's do it like is there any like
nerds or anything are you so used to
scenes like that that you just know what
you're doing
i think you get used to it and
it when you're shooting so many scenes
because we shot three and four
intertwined with one another when you
have any scenes it just really does feel
like another saying there's nothing
to be nervous about because you have
seven of them
so you just kind of yeah definitely are
used to that so the fandom surrounding
your characters the videos made online
of both of your characters i'm sure
you've seen them um
is that always surprising or still
overwhelming that you have that kind of
level of dedication to these characters
that you're playing
i'm really impressed i think
people's talent with when it comes to
the artwork and drawing i see that stuff
and i'm like
you know somebody should hire you
my stuff you know what i mean like i
think just the talent is very impressive
and the dedication and the passion
yeah here what's the most impressive
thing you've received from a fan
i've actually shot i was lucky enough to
when we were in bulgaria i did an
interview and i actually that showed it
but it was it still to this day is the
same thing as a picture of my late dog
that passed away someone made it like a
a really cool i don't even know how to
explain it but it was like
card
used to make artwork essentially but um
so hard to explain but the card is is
kind of it's not flat on the frame but
it's coming out of the frame i can't
even do it justice with words it's an
incredible art piece just as joe said
the talent amongst the fan base is
insane i'm so grateful it's not just
that i've got a bunch of hats t-shirts
stuff that i wear and love and and i'm
super super grateful yeah yeah it's so
wild um what was really fun to see in
the trailer here we got to see you punch
stephen moyer what was that moment like
for you
i wish i got to him in real life
because we're close enough now we're
close enough now that he will annoy me
to that extent some some sometimes but
no i love steve i learned so much from
him um such an honor you know playing
opposite him and and uh we've linked i
shot something in wales and he was
shooting in wales as well and he drove
down to where my hotel was and we
watched the west ham game together there
we watched one while we were shooting as
well so yeah um
uh i'd love to work with steve again and
all my experiences with him including
punching him in the face while massively
enjoyable yeah
jessie what was your experience like
with him
not that not the engine well we didn't
have the kind of scenes that they
had
yeah but um he's great he's the best
like everyone in this cast is just so
wonderful and
they're watching football together and
soccer together and we're playing
monopoly deal in the corner uh
great cause it does feel like a family
actually looking back it was like a
family atmosphere you know okay
nice
that's so special like that's amazing
like i can only imagine you signing on
to the first film and you're you're just
like okay let's see what people think
and then four films later is that
surreal
yeah
yeah and i think
we just lucked out and especially
because it was bulgarian it was covert
then uh
you got so lucky to to get along with
everyone when you're kind of stuck there
and you have to
find a way to pass the time
yeah okay so if ever because listen you
know people have reboots it happens so
quickly
would you be interested in exploring
these characters like 20 years down the
road do you want to see like what
they're up to and if they're together
i would say never say
never i think that would be so sick i
would love i would love to see what
happens with with um
with harding in 20 years i can't even
yeah
that'd be interesting for sure
cool well nice talking to you guys
congratulations i can't wait to see the
fourth one i'm such a fan of the first
two so yeah really pumped
thanks